right here
[Applause]
we're coming we're coming
I got you
we're coming
here
okay we're coming
here get out
frankly please get out of the house as a
buyer go go just get out just get out
get out anybody else besides the people
upstairs
go all the way across the road
[Music]
I won't
I got her
okay
yep hey
Drew
I got it
got it yep okay
[Music]
Frankfort can they see me
okay which door do you guys come down
the back in the smoke
[Music]
affirmative
hold this ladder
we're coming we're coming
I got you
we're coming here watch out
okay we're coming
[Applause]
let's get out just get out can I have
your kid Kinder baby
the car seat she's good
it's fun
[Music]
I won't I got her
can you pull that handle up so I can
hold on to it now
baby coming down
got it okay